okay so in this video we're going to go
over some of the common organelles of a
eukaryotic cell now an organelle is
simply a word that means small part so
just like the body has small parts
called organs cells have small parts
called organelles well there's a lot of
them so let's go ahead and get started
first thing I want to mention are the
three basic sections to the cell and all
cells need to take in food get rid of
waste and reproduce
well cells have three main sections to
them and inside of those three sections
are parts that allow them to take in
food get rid of waste and reproduce so
the first section you can see
highlighted by the flashing black line
the plasma membrane you might also hear
the plasma membrane simply called the
cell membrane we'll talk more about this
in a little bit pulsing in the picture
you can see the second main section the
nucleus you often hear the nucleus
called the control center we'll explain
why in a little bit and lastly we have
the cytoplasm now the arrow in the
picture looks like it's kind of just
pointing to empty space well cells are
not filled with empty space they're
filled with a part called the cytoplasm
we'll go into that in more detail let's
actually do the cytoplasm first here we
go
so the cytoplasm the first thing I want
to mention is that it's the jelly-like
material on the inside of the cell you
know when you look at diagrams sometimes
in a diagram a cell might look like it's
empty or filled with hollow air hallow
airspace and that's not true cells are
filled with a jelly-like liquidy
material called the cytoplasm and in
that cytoplasm most organelles float
with it you can see here's a list of a
few of the organelles that are floating
around in the cytoplasm we're going to
go and talk about all of these
throughout this video we'll talk about
what the mitochondria is what lysosomes
are and because the cytoplasm is a
jelly-like material and things are
floating around inside of it you often
under a microscope can actually see
parts floating around in this animation
here you can see what's known as
cytoplasmic streaming the green circles
that are drifting around inside of the
square cells the rectangular shaped
cells those green circles are plant cell
chloroplasts you can see in every
rectangular shaped plant cell there's a
few dozen chloroplasts yeah in in each
of these cells here this is known as
cytoplasmic streaming
okay well what about the job what does
the cytoplasm actually do well a lot of
chemical reactions take place within the
cell and chemical reactions take place
in the cytoplasm so that's kind of what
the job of the cytoplasm is it helps to
facilitate chemical reactions and it
also helps to dissolve solutes particles
that are in the cell carbohydrates
proteins these are all dissolved within
the actual cytoplasm of the cell so
that's really what the main function of
the cytoplasm is it also adds support to
the cell a pressure support for the cell
so the next part I want to mention is
called the plasma membrane also known as
the cell membrane and first of all it's
composition means what is it made from
it's a bilayer of lipids and proteins
earlier in the school year we learned
about lipids lipids a pit here the round
part represents the head two tails are
the fatty acids and what we mean by a
bilayer it's not just one layer but two
layers on top of one another this is a
bilayer of lipids right here in between
the bilayer of lipids are also proteins
I've labeled this protein channel and
you're going to see its importance in a
moment well the job of the plasma
membrane is to allow materials to to
pass to enter an exit you know small
molecules like water and oxygen h2o for
water Oh two for oxygen small molecules
like this can simply pass through the
lipid bilayer however larger molecules
larger molecules like glucose have to
pass through these protein channels and
that's what you see happening in the
animation and so that's really the job
of the cell membrane but the cell
membrane is what we call semipermeable
or selectively permeable that means that
it doesn't allow everything in and out
it only allows certain specific
molecules and ions and and charged
particles to enter or exit through the
plasma membrane
so when we come back to this picture we
saw earlier here we have the next part I
want to mention you can see the black
square highlighting the nucleus let's
zoom on in for a closer look when we
zoom on in here we have the nucleus and
you've heard maybe in middle school that
the job of the nucleus is to control the
cell's activity you often hear given the
nickname of the headquarters well what
does that mean well the reason we call
the nucleus the headquarters is because
it contains DNA and in the picture we
see five twisted strands of quarters
called chromatin chromatin are long
strands of DNA and DNA is the
instructions the blueprint the manual on
how to make proteins this is why we call
the nucleus the control center is
because the chromatin will be sending
out information to make proteins and
proteins do a lot of the work the vast
majority of the work inside of our cells
inside of our bodies are performed by
proteins so this is why the nucleus gets
the nickname of the control center also
inside the nucleus there's a round
object known as the nucleolus and the
job of the nucleolus is to make another
part of a cell another organelle called
the might excuse me called the ribosome
so the job of the nucleolus is to make
ribosomes and we're going to see what
ribosomes do in just a moment when we
look at this picture right here we can
see a nice electron microscope picture
the overall round object is the nucleus
you can see the dark spot is the
nucleolus a really nice picture here of
the nucleus and the nucleolus
so we come back here we have the box
highlighting the rough ER and the smooth
ER let's zoom on in and take a closer
look at the endoplasmic reticulum okay
first of all there's two kinds of ER
let's look at the rough ER first the ER
stands for endoplasmic reticulum the
rough ER the reason it's called rough is
that's covered in ribosomes so we
mentioned a moment ago that the
nucleolus makes ribosomes the ribosomes
then exit the nucleus and travel along
this tunnel system known as the rough ER
that's kind of the job of the rough ER
is to receive the ribosomes and
transporting and carry around the
ribosomes from one part of the cell to
another as you can see we can we finally
see what the job of a ribosome is
protein making ribosomes so that's the
job of a ribosome is to make a protein
so the rough ER will transport the
ribosomes as the ribosomes are making a
protein well if we look at this picture
here we have the purple nucleus identify
part a in the nucleus I hope you know
that the nucleolus the the lines the
purple lines identified by letter B
that's the DNA I hope you remember the
name of the DNA that's called chromatin
and then the outside of the nucleus in
pictures see I never mentioned the name
earlier but that's called the nuclear
envelope notice how the blue is the
rough ER and there's gray dots all over
it well look in the animation you see
grey dots exiting the nucleolus and the
animation and those gray dots are
traveling through the blue rough ER that
means those gray dots have to be the
ribosomes the job of ribosomes are to
make proteins we're going to go into
more on that in just a few moments
so what about the smooth ER well if the
rough ER is covered in ribosomes then a
little common sense the smooth ER is not
covered in ribosomes and you can see it
has a different job the job of the
smooth ER is to help make lipids and
fats and to help break down certain
toxins but the reason it gets its name
smooth ER is it's not covered in
ribosomes the rough ER is covered in
ribosomes and that's why it kind of has
a rough appearance to it so let's talk a
few moment a few extra moments about
those things called ribosomes they're
created by the nucleolus remember the
nucleolus is inside the nucleus they're
transported the ribosomes are
transported by the rough ER and as the
ribosomes are being transported by the
rough ER we now come to their job their
duty their function is to make proteins
and so if we highlight a few a few
ribosomes with that flashing black box
let's zoom on into a ribosome that's
attached to the rough ER well here we
have a ribosome and the reason what what
I mentioned a moment ago is its job is
to make a protein and what does is it
will gather individual amino acids and
earlier in the school year I hope you
learn you remember that amino acids are
the building blocks of proteins and so
here we see a ribosome is gathering and
connecting a bunch of amino acids into a
long chain this long chain of amino
acids is what we call a protein that's
the job of a ribosome is to gather and
build these amino acids into a larger
protein this process by the way is known
as translation we're going to learn
about it later in the school year though
so if we come back out here to our
diagram I've highlighted the flashing
box of the Golgi body let's zoom on in
to the Golgi body you might often hear
it called the Golgi apparatus or the
Golgi complex it's always going to be
called Golgi because it's named after
the scientist with the last name of
Golgi who discovered it and so the job
of the Golgi body is to receive proteins
that ribosomes made receive proteins for
that ribosomes made modify them sort
them and packaged them so they can be
exported from the cell and the Golgi
body will put the proteins into a
protective little envelope known as a
vesicle and so let's go ahead and review
what we've learned really quick
when we look at the process of shipping
out of protein in our animation we can
see the nucleolus is releasing a black
dot that black dot represents right a
ribosome so the nucleolus makes a
ribosome notice that ribosome then
travels through that rough ER that
system of tubes and tunnels so the
ribosome is traveling through the rough
ER making a protein let's zoom on in for
a closer look
so there's the ribosome okay now that we
can see the ribosome remember what the
job of a ribosome is it meant it makes a
protein and so there you see the word
protein now it's spelled PR OT ein but
it's not really put together properly so
this protein is not quite finished even
though the ribosome made it watch what
happens next
remember this is all happening at the
rough ER the protein is going to be
placed inside of a protective vesicle
and travel away where is it going I hope
you know where it's going
it's going to a Golgi body and so the
protein arrives at the Golgi body what
happens to the vesicle the vesicle fuses
and becomes a part of the Golgi body
well watch what happens the protein
moves through the Golgi body and is
eventually processed and modified and
ultimately is going to be released so
the Golgi body kind of makes the final
changes to the protein
well when the Golgi body releases the
protein it also will put it in a
protective vesicle so the vesicle is
going to be a protected little envelope
watch this the protein is put into a
protective vesicle and it's released the
vesicle fuses with the cell membrane and
then the protein is simply released from
the cell goes where it's needed
all right so if we were in class I would
have you turn to your neighbor and try
to work on these review questions so
we've kind of covered a lot of
information let's take a quick moment
you know pause the video pause the video
try to answer these seven questions I'm
going to go over the answers in three
two one
so which organelle builds proteins I
hope you know that's a ribosome which
organelles stores DNA well that's that's
the control center called the nucleus
which organelle produces ribosomes
that's the nucleolus it's found inside
the nucleus which organelle creates fats
and breaks down toxins well that's the
smooth ER which organelle number five
packages and releases proteins from a
cell that's the Golgi body remember
they're put inside of a protective
vesicle number six which organelle
allows materials to enter an exit a cell
that's the cell membrane also called the
plasma membrane number seven which
organelle links chains of amino acids
together that's the same thing as
question number one question number one
and question number seven it's the same
question just word it a little
differently because amino acids make
proteins let's try this one
same thing in class I would have you
work on this with the neighbor for a
minute but pause the video try to put
these four steps in order what comes
first second third fourth I'm going to
show the answer in three two one
okay so the answer is I hope you chose
step C first the nucleolus makes
ribosomes and then I hope you chose D
ribosomes will exit the nucleus and then
I hope you chose B the ribosomes are
going to travel along the rough ER and
create proteins and then finally I hope
you chose a the Golgi body will package
and export the finished protein inside
of a protective vesicle let's move on so
now we're back to our diagram and I've
highlighted the flashing box the
mitochondria let's zoom on in for a
closer look here we have the
mitochondria artist drawing on top
actual picture on the bottom and so the
job of the mitochondria you know in
middle school they give cute little
nicknames to sell parts in middle school
you may have been told this is the power
house but you may never have been told
why well it's the power house because
its job is to make an energy molecule by
the name of adenosine triphosphate ATP
so the mitochondria does a very
important process known as cellular
respiration and during the process of
cellular respiration it will create an
an energy molecule by the name of ATP
ATP is a molecule used by your cells for
energy so the analogy is the
mitochondria is kind of like the battery
of your cells
what's interesting about the
mitochondria is we're pretty certain the
mitochondria used to be a living
organism it used to be a basically a
bacterial cell but it has become part of
today's modern cells and this theory of
of how we think this happened is called
endosymbiosis I'll go over in more
detail in just a moment well when we
look at some of the evidence for why we
think the mitochondria used to be its
own living organism is because it has
its own DNA it has its own ribosomes
because it has its own ribosomes it can
manufacture its own proteins and the
mitochondria does something very
important to life the mitochondria can
reproduce and replicate so when you look
at this evidence it's pretty certa
pretty certain the mitochondria used to
be a free living organism a bacterial
species but it's become part of cells
how did that happen
that's what endosymbiosis tries to
explain I hope I can visualize that on
the next slide
okay so I really want to try to
visualize the endosymbiosis theory here
we have a large predator sell an orange
that's going to devour that red
mitochondria ancestor watch the watch
this so there it goes it just devoured
the mitochondria ancestor but the way we
think it were had happened is that red
mitochondria survives and divided and
multiplied it's just trapped inside of
the large predator cell well as the two
go about their lives the large predator
cell eventually is going to multiply and
divide as well and watch this when cells
divide they often grow and then they
split right down the middle and now you
have two cells two cells with the
mitochondria ancestors trapped inside of
them and then the process simply
continues so the the mitochondria
ancestors keep multiplying and then the
orange predator cell divides in half and
over time over millions and millions of
years the two have become so dependent
on one another that they can't survive
without them so this is kind of what the
what the endosymbiosis theory it tries
to explain is how cells became more
complex how did we obtain certain cell
parts and this is a the explanation for
how we think the mitochondria was
obtained
okay let's zoom on in let's focus on the
lysosomes back in our diagram here let's
zoom on in for a closer look at the
lysosomes and so the lysosomes contain
inside of them very powerful digestive
enzymes and that's my little animated
scissors here are showing so the blue
circle is the lysosome with the animated
scissors representing the enzymes inside
and so lysosomes have various jobs
number one is to break down food so here
we have a protein molecule that's being
taken into the cell and the protein is
being broken down into smaller parts
hope you know those smaller parts are
called amino acids here we have an
example of a white blood cell you
probably know white blood cells job is
to fight off infections like bacteria
and viruses well that's what we call
pathogens things that cause disease are
called pathogens and so here is a virus
or a bacteria and and notice how it just
landed on a white blood cell well what
happens is the white blood cell will
swallow up that pathogen put it inside
of a lysosome and those powerful
digestive enzymes will destroy it that's
one way that our immune system keeps us
healthy
and then there's the process called
autolysis where it's basically an aging
cell will destroy itself and so in our
in the middle of our picture here we
have a group of cells and I have the
animated scissors because what happens
is when cells are dying and aging they
will kind of self-destruct in a process
called autolysis where the lysosomes
will release all the digestive enzymes
and kill that cell it leaves behind a
gap but don't worry that gap will simply
be filled in as cells multiply so you've
heard the expression out with the old in
with the new
a couple other cell parts I want to
mention are used in movement and that's
the job of cilia and flagella now not
all cells move so not all cells have
cilia and flagella
but if cells move they probably have
either cilia or flagella so the picture
on the left shows the cilia short hair
like extensions there's numerous
hundreds and thousands of them per cell
wait a minute account very short stubby
almost look like eyelashes they're so
short and stubby the picture on the
right shows a sperm cell with a real
long flagella flagella is actually the
plural version flagellum is singular and
so the difference is really their length
the cilia short stubby flagella are long
and whip-like and usually there's only a
few of them may be only one flagellum
maybe two maybe three maybe four but not
nearly as many as the cilia well in that
picture on the right we have a sperm
cell about to penetrate a female egg
cell to create a fertilized egg also
known as a zygote let's have a little
fun with this
so after the fertilizer the sperm
fertilizes the egg that fertilized egg
is going to grow into a fetus here we
have a nice little ultrasound showing a
child growing inside of a pregnant woman
well eventually nine months later that
child's going to be born well let's
follow the life of this child
17 years go by 17 years later hey it's
your first day at high school and so
here you go welcome to high school and
hopefully four years after that you know
you'll be celebrating your graduation
from high school so this all started
because of that flagella that provided
the swimming movement to fertilize an
egg
so we look at the next part I want to
mention is the cell wall and so this is
the outermost layer of plants fungus and
bacterial cells so from left to right we
have plans fungi and bacteria notice
animals like humans do not have a cell
wall
well we also mentioned that the cell
wall is the outermost layer so when we
look at this picture we have a yellow
layer and a green layer so I hope you
know that yellow layer represents the
plasma membrane or the cell membrane and
the definition in the definition we see
that the outermost layer is the cell
wall so that's represented by the green
layer what about its job one of the jobs
of the cell wall is to add support it's
made from a real tough sturdy material
known as cellulose and so this adds some
of the support to plants and fungus and
bacterial cells that have
and so as I just mentioned the cell
walls made from a real tough material by
the name of cellulose it's very hard to
digest the reason for the picture is
celery has a lot of cellulose in it and
I'm sure you've had bites of celery it's
a very tough very fibrous plant very
hard to digest that's because you're
having to chew through a lot of
cellulose which is a main ingredient of
the cell wall and the cell wall really
started our understanding of cells
earlier in another video we learned that
Robert Hooke in 1665 again there's
really there's no real good pictures of
Robert Hooke so could we just have a
glass stained glass picture in a
Cathedral Robert Hooke in 1665 examined
cork and so he used a very primitive
microscope like this one in this picture
here and as I mentioned a moment ago he
examined cork now cork we might be
familiar with cork from you know wine
bottles but cork is actually tree bark
and he examined a real thin slice of
tree bark called cork and this is what
he saw in this picture here it is a
drawing that he made kind of a shocking
to believe that this picture right here
is a drawing made by hand but that's how
good of an artist he was and what you
see are hundreds of little tiny cells
but the outline of the cell is all
that's left he did a drawing of the cell
wall there was no nucleus cork and tree
bark is dead there was no nucleus when
he made the drawing there were no
mitochondria no vacuoles all that's left
and all you can see in the picture is
the drawing of the cell wall the cell
wall is very tough very strong and can
last for years and years after the cells
have died
so the next part I want to mention is
called the chloroplasts and so you might
know the job of the chloroplast is per
is to perform photosynthesis well here
are several dozen plant cells taken with
a microscope let's zoom on in for a
closer look when we zoom on in we can
see that inside of every cell are dozens
of those green round shaped objects
called chloroplasts they're inside every
single cell there's dozens of them per
cell so you know that the job of the
chloroplast is to perform photosynthesis
well inside of the chloroplast is a
chemical a green chemical by the name of
chlorophyll the job of chlorophyll is to
actually perform photosynthesis it will
absorb sunlight absorb carbon dioxide
absorb water and turn those into oxygen
and sugar particularly in the form of
glucose so what photosynthesis does is
it uses three ingredients water carbon
dioxide sunlight and we'll release two
products oxygen and sugar sugar called
glucose
just like the mitochondria the
chloroplast is thought to have evolved
according and become a cell part
according to the endosymbiosis theory we
think the chloroplast was also a free
living organism of bacteria in our
animation here we have a predator cell
devouring the chloroplast but not really
being digested that chloroplast ancestor
in green multiplies just like we saw a
moment to go with the mitochondria
ancestors and notice how the two are
just living together the green
chloroplast ancestors are just trapped
inside of the larger one well as time
goes by the largest cell divides and
splits into two and as years and go by
these two have become so dependent on
one another that they are now a part of
each other and the evidence to support
this is again the chloroplasts just like
the mitochondria have their own DNA and
ribosomes they make their own proteins
they can replicate and multiply and
divide these are all real strong
indicators that the chloroplasts were
probably once a free living organism all
by itself
but has become taken into the cell and
become part of modern cells
so the final one the last part I want to
mention is called the vacuole the job of
the vacuole is to store food store water
waste color pigments and in the picture
here you can see it's the big blue round
object in the middle of the cell
often in plants that is it's often the
largest part of a plant cell so in
plants it's often the largest central
meaning in the middle so we often think
of the nucleus being in the middle of a
cell often the vacuole is because it's
so big it pushes all the other parts to
the edges when we look at this little
animation right here again I mentioned
cytoplasmic streaming earlier here the
green circles represent chloroplasts but
they're all kind of revolving around the
central vacuole and so the central
vacuole is often so big it will push the
other organelles to the edge of the cell
so in plants there tends to be a large
central vacuole but it's not like that
with animal cells here's a diagram a
drawing of animal set of an animal cell
and the vacuoles are much smaller and
they're usually randomly scattered
throughout the cytoplasm but they still
serve the same purpose
they still store food store water store
waste and so that's really the job of
the vacuole right there well so there
you have it I mean there's a lot of cell
parts that we covered in this video here
so try and pause the video and work
through these questions if you're in my
biology class bring your answers to on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check your accuracy either before school
or after school good luck